i want to share a very exciting
natural remedy that you can take to
enhance your sleep
as you know sleep is so so important and
there's one remedy that i think will
work really good and you just take a
half a cup of this before bed and you
will sleep better
and that thing is
kefir
now what is kefir
well it's similar to yogurt
but it's better than yogurt it has a lot
more microbes it has between 12 to 50
different strains
where yogurt only has between like one
and three maybe maybe four or five
and as far as the quantity of microbes
not just the strains
kefir has five times more microbes than
yogurt and a lot of these microbes
survive
uh the stomach acids whereas they don't
with yogurt now the real unique thing
about kefir is it has not only friendly
bacteria
but it has friendly yeast so the
combination between friendly yeast and
friendly bacteria very important in
their functions also with kefir you're
going to get less problems with with
lactose intolerance
because those microbes in kefir eat
lactose milk sugar so you're going to
have less milk sugar and you're just
going to have less symptoms
especially gas when you have kefir
versus when you have yogurt and there's
a lot of other benefits with kefir
you'll have less liver fat you have less
allergies less constipation an improved
immune system better blood sugars better
blood pressure because of
how it acts as an ace inhibitor and
less
pathogens now
regarding sleep itself let's talk about
what kefir can do directly for your
sleep benefits
your microbes make serotonin in fact 90
of all the serotonin in your body comes
from your microbes so more of the right
microbes the more serotonin and
serotonin is a feel-good hormone it is a
hormone that can affect your mood it can
help reduce stress
not to mention
kefir makes microbes that can make
melatonin directly now there's several
things in your body to make melatonin in
fact all your cells can make a melatonin
but
mainly people think of the pineal in
your brain that makes melatonin but your
gut also makes melatonin both the
microbes as well as certain cells
specifically an interesting cell called
enterochromafin cell that's a it's kind
of an interesting cell because it's a
neuroendocrine cell so it's kind of a
half neurological and half
hormone
and those cells make melatonin and they
control inflammation
and they also control acids
and
kefir makes microbes that make the amino
acid tryptophan tryptophan turns into
serotonin and then it turns into
melatonin so again another thing that
will help you
sleep kefir also has a really good
source of bioavailable calcium which can
also help you get to sleep and stay
asleep now the microbes in kefir also
make certain b vitamins including b1
thymine which greatly helps stress
especially if you're trying to go to
sleep and you're thinking and you're
thinking and you can't turn it off
b1 is what you need
and
the lactobacillus microbe in kefir
helps reduce
cortisol now try to sleep when your
cortisol is too high it's impossible so
anything you can do to reduce cortisol
will help you sleep so that's quite a
few things that directly help your sleep
that stem from kefir
now as far as the type of kefir that i'm
going to recommend i highly recommend
that you make your own there's a really
great website that i get my kefir
crystals from that it's like a starter
little
group of microbes it's called kefir live
grains but there's no grains in it and
the website that i go to is called happy
herbalist.com and i don't get any cut or
i'm not affiliated with this website but
it's just a really good source of high
quality um very inexpensive
uh starter
kefir grains i would highly recommend if
you have the choice use goat's milk but
you can use cow's milk and on their site
they explain how to do it they send you
a little guide and i will put the link
down below but basically we do is you
just take one tablespoon and you put it
right into
two cups of milk and you don't need to
heat it or anything you just take it out
of the fridge you put it on your counter
put a little cloth top or even a paper
towel with a little
rubber band and you just wait for a day
24 hours and you have kefir which is not
as thick as yogurt but you're going to
have a huge benefit of all these great
microbes and you can experiment with the
temperature to make it a little bit
warmer or a little more concentrated or
leave it out for a little bit longer to
make it more sour which means there's
going to be less lactose in there and
more lactic acid and the cool thing is
you can take these grains out and keep
them in a little bit of milk and then
keep reusing them over and over and over
and this way you have a fresh batch of
kefir
on a regular basis
and i think the next best video for you
to watch
would be the one on
using other things to help yourself
sleep better
you